Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Alessio Politi
In molti pensano
che il lavoro del cuoco
non è un lavoro per donne,
ed è per questo
che ci sono poche donne chef.
"Perché è un lavoro di forza"
aveva detto lo chef Vissani a dicembre:
"Le donne non riescono
a sollevare pentoloni pesanti.
Dopo un po' crollano, mollano".
"Perché è un lavoro estenuante
e psicologicamente stressante"
pensano in molti:
d'altronde, lavori non meno
di 12 ore al giorno, e se ti va bene.
Il fatto è che pure
i numeri parlano chiaro.
È vero: molte poche donne
avanzano nella carriera in cucina.
Se prendiamo come campione
i ristoranti stellati Michelin al mondo,
è sorprendente notare
come solo il quattro percento
siano guidati da chef donne:
pochissimi.
Perché?
Le risposte più comuni a questa domanda,
che troviamo anche solo digitando sul web
"Perché ci sono poche donne chef?"
sono tre.
Una: perché le cucine professionali
sono dei luoghi prettamente maschili,
dove le donne fanno fatica ad inserirsi,
sono soggette a battute sessiste
e fanno fatica a comunicare
e a farsi rispettare.
Due: perché la donna è entrata
nel mondo del lavoro
relativamente da pochi decenni,
e quindi il fatto
che ci siano poche donne chef
sarebbe un retaggio culturale del passato.
Tre: c'è una difficoltà oggettiva.
Con tutte quelle ore di lavoro,
come fai ad avere figli
e a prendertene cura?
Io credo che queste risposte
siano tutte e tre vere.
Eppure, non mi sembrano
del tutto sufficienti
per dar conto di una
percentuale così bassa.
Dai, il quattro percento è ridicolo!
Ci avviciniamo alla percentuale di donne
che negli Stati Uniti guidano gli aerei.
Ripeto: guidano gli aerei!
Qui stiamo parlando di un'attività
che noi donne svolgiamo
dalla notte dei tempi,
cioè cucinare.
E che queste tre risposte
non siano del tutto sufficienti,
mi pare evidente dal fatto
che oggi molti lavori
prima esclusivamente maschili
sono svolti da donne competenti,
che sono imprenditrici, manager,
avvocati e tanto altro.
E che, se vogliono, possono coniugare
anche la vita privata.
In questa sede,
io vorrei provare ad avanzare
una quarta ipotesi di risposta.
Mi sembra che ci sia qualcosa
nel modo di intendere
la professione di chef oggi -
professione che sta, tra l'altro,
avendo un successo inedito -
qualcosa che impedisce
e rallenta alle donne
la possibilità di fare
carriera, ed emergere.
Credo che questo qualcosa
vada cercato nel concetto di creatività.
Che cosa si richiede allo chef, oggi?
Di essere creativo.
A cosa aspira il giovane cuoco, oggi?
Ad avere il proprio ristorante,
diventare uno chef,
esprimere la propria creatività
e dunque realizzarsi.
Sembra, quasi,
che la creatività sia il ponte
verso una realizzazione personale
in questa società.
Se sei un genio creativo,
ti elevi dalla mediocrità
e puoi pure fare soldi.
È in quanto creativo,
qualcosa di simile ad un artista,
che lo chef è diventato una star oggi.
Questa creatività ha a che fare
con lo stupore, l'emozione, la genialità.
Ma cos'è la creatività?
Ha davvero a che fare -
è davvero legata a doppio filo
con la meraviglia,
con il famoso "Effetto Wow!",
con l'esprimersi del genio
individuale dell'artista chef?
Io credo di no,
o forse credo che ci siano
tante accezioni di creatività.
E mi sembra che questa,
in particolare, sia legata al maschile.
Permettemi di generalizzare un po':
mi sembra che si fondi
su di un insieme di valori
che fanno più parte del carattere maschile
rispetto a quello femminile.
Mi sembra un modello legato alle dinamiche
di una società costruita su due generi:
il maschile e il femminile.
E mi sembra che questo modello
sia veicolato già nell'infanzia,
attraverso i giochi e l'educazione.
Ai bambini vengono insegnati i giochi
dove tiri fuori la tua forza
e la tua sicurezza di sé,
un'idea di conquista,
di competizione, di sicurezza;
a noi bambine viene insegnato
a giocare con le bambole,
ad essere brave, pazienti,
carine, non aggressive.
Al massimo,
a gestire delle situazioni complesse
in modo diligente.
L'educazione delle bambine
è qualcosa che ha poco a che vedere
con questa creatività
competitiva, affermativa.
Non è un caso che la storia della cucina
in cui progressivamente
si afferma questa idea,
questo imperativo
della creatività geniale,
sia una storia fatta di uomini.
Nell'Ottocento, insieme all'affermarsi
dell'artista genio,
si delinea anche l'immagine
del cuoco artista;
e poi è nel Novecento,
fino all'inizio 2000,
in cui vediamo delinearsi
l'immagine, tutta maschile,
di mostro sacro della cucina.
Pensiamo a Bocuse, a Ducasse,
fino ad arrivare a quel gran genio
che è stato Ferran Adrià,
lo spagnolo Ferran Adrià.
Con Ferran Adrià,
viene lanciato l'imperativo assoluto
della genialità in cucina.
Da Ferran in poi,
il grande chef è l'inventore geniale
che rompe gli schemi:
tutti gli altri sono cuochi.
Su questi argomenti ho riflettuto molto,
anche perché io lavoro
con il mio compagno.
Che è chef anche lui,
e che nel mondo della cucina
è considerato, e forse si considera,
particolarmente creativo
in questa accezione del termine.
E quante volte sono stata colta
dalla sindrome dell'impostore!
Sicuramente, tutte le volte
che ho vinto dei premi,
e mi dicevo: "ma dai, ci sarà qualcuna,
o qualcuno, più creativo di me".
Ci ho messo del tempo a capirlo.
Ma poi alla fine, l'ho capito
che il problema stava proprio lì.
In quel concetto di creatività
legata al genio,
che poteva essere messo in discussione.
Io credo che sia abbastanza diffuso
in questa società;
e credo, anche,
che le donne dovrebbero liberarsi
da questo senso
di insicurezza e di incapacità
nei confronti di un tale modello,
e trovare la propria dimensione -
volendo, anche creativa - come chef.
Se in molti settori,
tra cui quello della ristorazione -
ma attenzione, non della cucina:
sono diversi -
il contributo delle leadership femminili
è riconosciuto, ormai,
come portatore di miglioramenti
e funzionalità nelle aziende,
io credo che questo, nella cucina,
non sia ancora accaduto.
Proprio perché il modello dominante
si basa su questo concetto
di creatività legata al genio,
che rimane tutto sommato
un modello maschile.
Allora, quale creatività?
Io non ho una risposta unica:
forse nessuna, forse tantissime.
Io so solo che non mi sento
un genio creativo,
ma che riconosco oggi la mia forza
nella fantasia costante del pensare
i piatti, i menù, la mia cucina;
nel prendermi cura del cliente,
delle persone, dell'esperienza culinaria;
nel fare della cucina,
e della tecnica culinaria,
uno strumento per vivere appieno,
interagire, rispettare
la natura, i suoi prodotti,
l'ambiente in cui viviamo.
Vorrei fare un piccolo esempio,
che è solo un esempio di un modo di fare,
o di una creatività in cucina:
noi, da quest'anno,
siamo riusciti ad eliminare
la plastica usa e getta in cucina -
è quasi un mezzo miracolo -
Togliendoci di torno
sacchetti sottovuoto e pellicola.
Io lo vedo come uno degli atti
su cui si può puntare
l'attenzione, per esempio.
Ora, credo che ci sia
un traguardo da raggiungere
su cui tutti siamo d'accordo:
è necessario aumentare
la percentuale di donne chef.
E per fare questo,
forse è necessario far crollare un modello
che è stato il ponte per un successo
prevalentemente maschile,
e aprire delle vie funzionali,
anche, al successo femminile.
Si potrebbe, ad esempio,
cominciare a pensare la cucina
come una tecnica che può avere
dei risultati altissimi,
e non solo come a un'arte
vincolata alla genialità del singolo.
I media, le guide,
potrebbero aiutarci in questo:
aprire spazi ai nuovi linguaggi,
scompigliare un po' le carte dei generi,
non limitarsi a dare i premi
con le quote rosa.
Credo quindi, per finire,
che liberarsi da certi valori di genialità
potrebbe permettere a molte più donne
di fare successo ed emergere in cucina.
E credo che potrebbe essere
un cambiamento innovativo
trainante anche, perché no,
per l'intera società.
Grazie.
(Applausi)